ce ne sont pas des cavaliers décoché
mais des meneurs depuis un peu plus
d'une journée
ces stages est révolu sous l'oeil
attentif de guillaume singer responsable
des cures d'attelage au haras des
bréviaires en attelage on est tout de
suite au gain voilà il ne faut pas
attendre d'avoir une bonne assiette de
ce2 se tenir sur sur sur ces deux
étriers là on s'assoit dans un siège on
a les guides on pilote francheval tout
de suite mais avant de s'essayer au
galop le meneur doit préparer son
attelage on met au cheval un harnais qui
nous posait une sellette d'un collier
d'inventer et de brides la pièce
principale ce sont les guides de long
grain qui vont permettre de diriger la
monture sa célèbre iphone base ensuite
position de base et aides et on met
toujours le petit doigt avec les autres
parce que là comme ça c'est pas ça c'est
une réflexe de cavaliers jérôme apprend
à ses stagiaires comment conduire les
chevaux avec les deux guides un peu
d'entraînement pour savoir mener au
carré puis ne reste qu'à attacher la
voiture et se rendre dans la carrière
aujourd'hui les chevaux vont travailler
les trois allures le pas le trot et le
galop un programme pas très différent
d'une séance de dressage habituel des
exigences physiques moins lourde que
pour les cavaliers traditionnel experts
ou novices ils découvrent de nouvelles
sensations
on découvre des sensations de contact
accueil cheval que l'on n'a pas vraiment
lorsqu'on fait de la balade avec des
personnes en calèche quoi il ya un
contact avec le cheval permanent dans le
travail hatley ça permet aussi de voir
d'autres horizons d'aller se promener en
promenade en forêt
voilà quoi et tout en continuant à
travailler à avoir une d'aidé optique de
travail sur le sur son chemin après
quatre jours les stagiaires sont
autonomes et maîtrise seule leur voiture
et leur cheval alors si vous vous sentez
l'âme d'un meneur l'attelage et peut
être fait pour vous